who's looking for a lift this morning it
is time for the uplift at eight where we
share stories that you bring some joy to
your day and we got a story that's gonna
bring you some more vlad to your day
yeah good to see you so here's a
question uh who do you need by your side
when you're about to get married and
you're dealing with all those
last-minute stresses
your best friend of course british bride
rachel kemplin was devastated her
longtime friend kate wilson said she
could not make the big day because she
just moved to australia then the night
before the wedding
a present arrived watch this
what is this
surprise
[Music]
surprise kate had been planning the
surprise visit for months with rachel's
now husband and sister-in-law we caught
up with the two friends a couple of days
after the ceremony rachel says having
her best friend by her side has made all
the difference
she knows
me inside out and always knows the right
thing to say
and i was incredibly nervous about
walking down the aisle um
and before i walked down the aisle she
came up stairs and sang hold on by
wilson phillips with me from the film
bridesmaids just to keep me let me cry
together distance doesn't really really
mean anything when you have such
the level of love for each other that we
have
so the two hadn't seen each other for a
few years and for those who are curious
i was not but if you are curious uh the
intel on the bridesmaids dress in the
shoes to match she was ready to go she
had spoken to the bridesmaids earlier so
that's why
she matched but the bigger message
you're right or die at your size that's
right one of life's biggest moments can
i say though like that's a you that's a
little scary surprise that you're
throwing on the bride like she's
stressed enough and then you're good
that is true
i would have been there earlier it's
like a buzzer beater right now i guess
yeah i guess
it matters at the last second with the
clothes in the shoes yes and wilson
phillips hold on you got to have that
story like you sing it and you feel
better about the day those surprise
videos never get old just seeing
somebody just break down in tears
because they're surprised by a loved one
never gets old be funny if they were
like hanging out with each other and not
with her like soon to be husband
i don't care about you i'm just here to
hang out with my best friend great job
glad we appreciate it i do feel uplifted
right now